bruce aryan's joining us tampa bay head
coach uh
you know what my staff didn't realize
how great a running quarterback you were
in college
do your do your players know i think you
had 11 touchdowns one year didn't you
yeah the record held for a long time and
then gerard evans beat it but he played
15 games i only played 11.
oh there's an asterick on it how was
your arm
i was very average when i when we were a
passing team i was a running cornerback
we're a running team i just
does it help you look at the offense
differently having played the position
oh totally yeah the the having played in
so many different offenses in college
you know had the pleasure playing for
dan henning when don strzok led the
nation in passing has his backup
and then running the wishbone so uh saw
two totally sized
different sides of the game when i was
playing who was your favorite
quarterback growing up
johnny onitis the baltimore colts were
my team
did you ever meet him i i did
uh they came and played a basketball
game against a radio station and we were
like the preliminary game
and we dressed in the same locker room
so i put his trench coat on it they left
i put his trench coat on his hat at that
time he had he had a commercial for a
deodorant soap
i was walking around the locker room
with his coat on
what struck me when i met him was that
he wasn't tall
because you know growing up when you saw
like when i met jack nicklaus
i thought the golden bear is like six
two six three
johnny united was like five eleven it
felt like maybe six feet
lenny moore uh mike curtis i mean
everybody in the baltimore coals those
are my heroes
uh when you went down 10 to nothing to
aaron rodgers what were you thinking on
the sidelines
exhale you know just we were holding our
breath we were
we came out a little bit tight on both
sides of the ball and uh
you know i think todd both did a great
job with the defense on the side you
know
we're letting him out of the pocket got
everything covered
um let's just exhale and go play faster
and that defense it felt like they were
kind of conservative or you weren't uh
pushing
rogers or being aggressive like that at
least it felt like that in the beginning
then all of a sudden
it was like olly ali income free let's
go get him let's let's force him to make
some
some magic here was that the game plan
uh no we actually went after early we
just let him out of the pocket
he scrambled on the first third and ten
we dumped somebody
kept rushing the quarterback let the
back out and it's just a matter of
doing your job uh but again the game
plan was to stop the run shut the run
down and go get him
and you know you start to watch this
team now i don't know how many games it
usually takes you
each season before you go okay now i
know who my team is
do you know who your team is now
i think we've known defensively
offensively we're stressed still
scratching the surface
we've missed so much time in the
offseason so each week's a new week for
us offensively and uh
with all the injuries on offense uh
getting guys back now i think we can
start finding ourselves
and you know just trying to figure this
out you gotta obviously
you know tom knew there and you didn't
get the off-season workouts you got
injuries with your wide receiver like
how dynamic can this
offense be or do you want it to be oh i
think it could be one of the tops you
know
we're running the ball well right now
offensive line's healthy knock on woods
and and blocking well so with with
ronald jones running and getting leonard
fournette back
um just makes the game easy for tom
and then now the receivers are all
getting healthy
and he didn't even practice those guys
for three weeks
and so it should just get better and
better did you guys make a run at
le'veon bell
no you're fine with the running backs
that you have
oh yeah we got more than enough
by the way seven questions before i
brought up tom brady's name that might
be a record coach
there you go yeah how's gronk doing
because it felt like he was kind of
laboring there
starting this season but uh you know he
did have a touchdown catch so how would
you assess where he is right now
i think he's he's playing really really
good you know as his number
when teams want to double cover mike
evans it kind of opens up the field for
grunk
and uh and he he was working through it
early in the season he's in great shape
and uh i think we're doing a better job
of coaching
um him up a little bit and and tom
too as far as when we're seeing
different coverages where we want to go
with the ball
is gronk goofy he's uh he's
unusual he's a hell of a lot of fun
though man he is a
lot of fun give me an example
just talking to him like dude did your
elevator go all the way to the top
i mean i'm not sure but uh it is fun
can you imagine belichick though and him
you know how belichick is
like you've got a sense of humor and you
know you're pretty
back and forth with players but i can't
imagine belichick
you know just laughing at gronk or
allowing gronk to be gronk
i don't yeah i just don't think you can
help it and i think bill probably had a
lot of smiles on his face when he was
coaching him too
what is it about brady that uh has
surprised you so far
his interaction with young players um i
think is outstanding he's like another
coach
uh and you know you as a coach you can
tell a guy keep pumping his arms keep
doing this
come out of your brakes but when he says
it they listen for some reason
and uh it's just amazing seeing him work
with these young guys
because of the injuries to chris and
mike and
having to put young guys in there who
never played and him just coaching them
up
trusting them um i i you know everybody
gets on him by getting on people i love
when he gets on people hell i don't have
to do it then
but you know everything you do this year
because tom's in town
is scrutinized like i don't know if
you've ever felt this way before where
the national media is going oh do you
hear what aryan said
uh about great like that this is these
are headlines here
like have you felt this way before at
any time in your coaching career
where everybody was watching what you
were doing and scrutinizing it
not really it's uh this is this is
different we knew we were getting into
and
just embrace it and have fun with it
yeah
but you know bill parcells used to yell
at phil sims
when lawrence taylor would make a
mistake like can you
yell at tom so everybody knows that
i'm yelling at tom and and you know
nobody's untouchable here
uh that that's happened in practice but
it's
more blaine gabriel gets to ask joan all
the time
so you don't yell at tom you yell at
gabbard oh yeah and he relates the
message
but tom tom hears me so
it's always that way with ben byron left
witch and charlie bass got cussed out
all the time
instead of roethlisberger oh yeah well
you know
you're dealing with egos though when
you're dealing with the quarterback like
is it more fragile dealing with a
quarterback than any other position
oh totally totally uh their their
mindset
the the vibe that they're in you know
you don't want to change it
uh but you want to get your point across
too uh
the ball should be here and uh it's it's
it's fun though
it's it's been a great great time
coaching him
but i would think with wide receivers
because they're always open
and they're always complaining that they
would be hard to deal with too
i've had some in the past this group is
as selfless as i've ever been around you
know mike
evans as long as we're he don't we win
lose draw if he catches one or he
catches ten he's the same guy
chris godwin's the same way so we're
very very fortunate in that regard
who was the diva that you had yeah let's
just say there were a few
how many uh how many kango hats do you
own
oh gosh about 30 or 40 but they're all
new era
oh okay do you have the creamsicle
no i couldn't get it made i'm still
working on that one
oh that'd be good though you bring when
are you guys going creamsicle
i think it's going to be a while uh you
know hopefully next year when the
uniform
rules loosen up a little bit make have a
different helmet also you can't do it
this year
no no because of the helmet that you can
only have one helmet
oh man tell tom to do it they won't find
him
for sure yeah the commissioner of course
he won't find tom uh coach
congratulations and uh good luck you got
sunday night against the raiders and uh
that'll should be fun at the raiders so
thanks for joining us
you bet anytime all right that's uh
bruce erins buccaneers head coach